president biden has signed an executive
order this earth day expanding his
administration's efforts to address the
climate crisis he's in the west this
morning pushing for a multi-billion
dollar package nancy cordes is in
seattle traveling with the president and
nancy he has some pretty specific agenda
items
he does and in fact jimmy the executive
order that he's signing here in seattle
today on this earth day is aimed at
protecting old growth forests on federal
lands across the country now
environmentalists applaud that goal but
some of them were hoping for bolder
action more than one year into his
presidency
just days before the president touched
down here in seattle a new study
confirmed what many here already suspect
that worsening wildfires in the pacific
northwest are changing air pollution
patterns across the country causing a
yearly surge of unhealthy carbon
monoxide we need to get off this roller
coaster relying on oil
we need to declare america's energy
independence
on this earth day president biden is
renewing some of the pledges he made as
a candidate global warming is an
existential threat to humanity
but many of his promises are still works
in progress with half a trillion dollars
worth of clean energy incentives stalled
in the senate we've been frustrated with
president biden and the administration's
unwillingness to use the full might of
the federal government eric pica is
president of the environmental group
friends of the earth for example just
last week they announced brand new
leasing on
federal lands for oil and gas and this
goes against his pledge they made during
the campaign
that reversal came after the war in
ukraine drove up oil prices and it's
vladimir putin's gas price increase and
a recent cbs news poll shows that as
confidence in the economy has dropped
the number of americans who think the
u.s needs to address climate change now
has also fallen to just below 50 percent
in fact when americans were asked about
top priorities climate change came in
last
the president's administration is
working on limiting greenhouse gases
they're going to eventually
release a series of rules and he has
vowed to cut greenhouse gases in half by
2030 but many environmentalists worry
that his window for transformative
lasting change will close if republicans
win back control of the house
in this november's midterm elections
tony
all right nancy thank you very much